FEMALE SPEAKER: OK,
hi, welcome, everybody.
This is the second speaker
series for the month of Pride.
Today we are joined by
Wilson Cruz and [INAUDIBLE].
Wilson is a GLAAD national
spokesperson as well as
a representative and advocate.
And you've also
probably seen him
in shows like "Ally
McBeal," "Grey's Anatomy,"
and on "Rent."
So without further ado,
Wilson Cruz, please.
[APPLAUSE]
WILSON CRUZ: OK, I don't
need to look at that all day.
Hi.
How are you?
Thanks so much for coming
out and joining us here
in the room.
I understand there's
lots of people watching,
or hopefully lots of people
watching from their desks
here on campus at
the Googleplex.
So welcome to all of you.
Thank you for joining us.
And thank you for
having me here today.
I'm actually really proud to
be here to speak to all of you
and to meet all of you.
It's pretty amazing
for me because I'm not
very technologically advanced
to be on the campus of Google.
I mean, I can barely
turn the computer on.
But I do have an
app that I would
like to pitch for you today.
No, I'm kidding.
I'm just kidding.
How many times do you
guys get to hear that when
somebody comes and visits?
I am a disruptor, but I'm
a completely different kind
of disruptor.
I am very proud to be
here during Pride Month.
But for me and everyone at
GLAAD-- which is where I work
and the organization
that I represent--
every day is Pride Month.
Every day is Pride Day.
And for almost 30 years, GLAAD
has been using the stories
in the media to
shape the narrative
and to provoke dialogue
about LGBT equality
so that everyone, no matter
who you are or where you are,
can live the life that you love.
First, I'd like to ask,
is there anyone here,
by a show of hands who
identifies as L, G, B, or T,
or Q, for questioning?
Yeah?
Oh, nice.
Big.
Most of the people in the
room, for those of you
who are watching
from your desks.
Is there anyone here who
identifies as an ally?
Thank you very much.
We would be nowhere without you.
But if you did not raise
your hand, no pressure.
But actually, pressure--
pressure first
to be inclusive of
our entire community.
And second because part
of the idea of Pride Month
is about being out and
open about who you are
and what you represent.
For anyone that's feeling a
little bit shy or not sure
if it's safe to identify at LGBT
or even as an LGBT ally here
today, I hope that by the
time we finish here today,
I have been able to
convince you otherwise,
that this really
is a safe place.
That's what I do at my
job every day at GLAAD.
But really, it's
been my life's work.
It really has been my life.
Because at GLAAD,
it's always personal.
My relationship with
this organization
started almost 20 years ago.
I know, you're thinking,
you're barely 20 yourself.
But no, alas, I am not.
It actually started 20
years ago around 1995,
when I had the pleasure of
accepting the Outstanding Drama
Series GLAAD Media Award for my
very first television series,
"My So-Called Life."
For those of you who may
have not watched it by now,
I played the very
first gay teenager
on primetime television,
Rickie Vasquez.
And it was through
this experience
on "My So-Called
Life" that I witnessed
the power of how media
can effect change.
I saw how one story,
my story, really,
if handled responsibly
and accurately,
could change
perspectives and lives.
People came to know
Rickie and to love him.
Because finally
there was a story
of a young person on a
journey of self-discovery
and of self-acceptance that
was being told honestly.
And viewers grew to
understand and to love him
because of this.
And among those viewers
was my very own father.
You see, just a few
months before we actually
started filming the series,
I came out to my own dad.
And it did not go well.
He actually kicked
me out of my house
because I told him
that I was gay.
And we did not speak
for almost a year.
But he broke his silence when
he turned on the television
one day and watched an episode
of "My So-Called Life" in which
my character, Rickie, was
thrown out of his own home
and beaten because he had
come out to his family.
My father watched that episode
and afterwards picked up
the phone and said that he
wanted me to come home to talk.
So through the years,
when I've received letters
from young people
or I've met people
who were affected by that show
who said that Rickie saved
their lives or helped them to be
able to speak to their parents
about who they really
are, I could tell them
that I honestly understood
what they meant by that.
Because Rickie did
that for me as well.
That's the power
of storytelling.
And I've experienced it over
and over again in my career,
whether it was playing
Rickie Vasquez or Angel
in "Rent" on Broadway or playing
Dr. Junito Vargas on the LOGO
series "Noah's Arc."
These were both gay
characters living with HIV.
I've learned that
stories like these
serve as not only
entertainment but as vessels
of empathy, which can
lead to acceptance.
Those are the opportunities
that I've always
looked for as an actor.
They've been the most satisfying
and gratifying experiences
of my life, to be able to
not only do what I love
and also be able to inform
people about what our lives are
really like-- that to
me is a perfect marriage
and a perfect experience for me.
And many people throughout my
career for the last 20 years
are always asking me
if I'm afraid of being
typecast in just gay roles.
And I hate that question.
I really do.
Later on, we're going to do Q&A.
And I'll answer any question.
But that question
always gets to me.
Because I'm always
like, well, do
you think that they ask Brad
Pitt or Ryan Gosling or George
Clooney if they're
afraid of being
typecast in straight roles?
No, they don't ask them that.
Being straight or gay doesn't
define a character to me.
It's just an aspect
of who that person is.
It's incredible to me that
they think just because you're
playing a gay
character that he's
just like every other gay
character you've ever played.
But LGBT people are
varied and complicated.
Every character I've played
has been an individual.
And every one has
been different for me
and has helped me
illuminate what
it means to be a queer
person in the world,
whether it was an ambitious
political operative
on "The West Wing" or the
nanny for the youngest
Salinger child on
"Party of Five"
or a man doing all he could to
make his domestic partnership
ceremony in Seattle
feel as special
as a wedding on
"Grey's Anatomy."
I've worked to make these
people and their experiences
real and honest and as
complicated as all of us are.
And I'm proud to say that I
continue to be fortunate enough
to be given that opportunity,
to be an actor who
tells the stories
of our community.
And today, as a
matter of fact, I'm
very proud to say that today
is the DVD release of a film
that I was proud to do
with Lukas Haas called
"Meth Head," which takes
a look at the effects
of meth addiction
in our community
and how it affected
this gay couple.
I've seen how devastating that
drug has been to our community.
And I think the film does a
really great job of depicting
what that's like
for a lot of people.
And this fall, I'll be part
of one of the most anticipated
new series to come
to television on Fox,
called the "Red
Band Society," where
I'll be playing a nurse
alongside Oscar winner Octavia
Spencer.
It takes place in the
pediatric ward of a hospital
as we help guide the lives
of a group of young people
who live in that pediatric ward.
And we help them through
this very difficult time.
And they create a bond.
And they create this society
they called the Red Band
Society.
Because once you have
your first surgery,
they all get a red band.
And the show itself
will actually
include many LGBT
characters, including
mine, who has a very odd
name-- Kenji Gomez-Rejon.
Do I look like a Kenji?
But I'll take it.
These are the kinds of stories
I came to GLAAD to tell.
I wanted to help GLAAD
advocate for not just
more representation in
the media but a diversity
in that representation of
LGBT people and experiences
and a more diverse
view of who we are.
GLAAD's work is
comprehensive in scope
and affects every aspect
of an LGBT person's life.
We work every day to
ensure that everyone
knows the truth about
who we really are
and that they feel
and understand
that we are an integral
part of the global family
with the same hopes and dreams
and aspirations as everyone
else.
And lately, we've had
some astounding successes.
And a lot of that has a lot
to do with you and people
like you.
And I'll explain those
triumphs in detail.
But first, let me give you
a little background on what
the state of LGBT equality
is in America right now
and tell you what our goals are.
We've clearly come a long way.
It's a good time to
be out in America.
Last year, our nation
made a huge step forward
when the Supreme Court dismissed
DOMA, the Defense of Marriage
Act, and decided that
California's Prop 8
was unconstitutional.
And props to all of you
who fought against Prop 8.
That was a long-fought battle,
a long, hard-fought battle.
I think it was the moment that
really pushed this younger
generation, this X, Y Generation
to really get involved
and really made it real for them
that this wasn't something that
was just going to
happen automatically.
But it was something
that we were
going to have to advocate
for and fight for.
So I'm very proud of
the state of California
and everyone who worked so
hard to make that happen.
And because of that,
marriage equality
is now legal in 19 states.
And every morning,
I have to wake up,
and I have to figure out
if that's still true.
Because it's happening so fast.
All of us at
GLAAD-- sometimes we
have these posters
in our offices.
And we have to mark very
happily the number off
and replace it with the number
19 or 20, hopefully soon.
And GLAAD and
other organizations
are on the ground in the
other 31 states to make sure
that anyone can get
married to whomever
they love in any state.
We still have our struggles
on the legal front
and the cultural front.
But we're on our way.
America's also becoming
safer for LGBT students,
since bullying has
become a national issue.
Yet still today, 8
out of 10 students
report being verbally
harassed for being gay.
GLAAD's Help Engage Youth
project, better known as HEY
or "Heeey!"
Spirit Day and GLSEN, which is
the Gay and Lesbian Straight
Educators Networks
Safe Schools Program,
are all making a
difference so that kids
can go to school in safe
and accepting environments.
And we don't just mean safe
and accepted by their peers,
but by their educators
and administrators, too.
The sports world has also
taken miraculous leaps
in the past year or two.
Athletes like Michael Sam, Jason
Collins, and Brittney Griner
will go down in history for
breaking through the AstroTurf
ceiling.
Is that a thing, the
AstroTurf ceiling?
No, it's not?
OK.
Does that exist?
That'd be kind of cool,
when you think about it.
But anyway, what GLAAD
does-- we work very closely
with many athletes, including
those three that I just
mentioned, on helping
them shape the narrative
of their public
coming-out stories
and to encourage
the media to cover
those stories in a fair
and non-salacious way.
And now little kids
all over this country
can play tee ball and
powder puff football
and know that they can
succeed and that who they are
won't impede them from
achieving their dreams.
And who knew that the 2014
Olympics would turn out
to be such a hot-button
issue for LGBT rights
and protections
around the globe?
But it did.
You could not hear
the name Sochi
without thinking about
the safety and rights
of LGBT athletes and people in
Russia and around the world.
And that's because of
GLAAD's work with activists
living in Russia, with news
outlets and athletes themselves
to get the message of equality
and acceptance out there.
GLAAD's focus since the start
has always been on media
because we know what
a powerful force
it is in shaping opinions and
changing hearts and minds.
When people know us,
when they know our story,
when they feel that
we've been in their home
on their television sets, and
they've welcomed us in in order
to share a piece
of who we are, they
feel like we're a part of their
society and their families.
And when they walk into
those voting booths,
they vote with us
more often than not,
when that is the case.
And that's why GLAAD focuses
so much on the media.
That's why our work
really revolves around it.
For example, transgender actress
and activist and my friend
Laverne Cox on the cover of
"Time" just a few weeks ago.
It's a huge deal.
For many people, Laverne Cox
is the first transgender person
that they know.
And her story is powerful,
and it's changing the way
that people see
transgender people
and understand their experience.
And it seems like every day,
some LGBT actor or executive
is coming out like
it's no big deal.
And that's because it isn't.
And it isn't anymore
because of people like you.
And while LGBT people
have had huge successes
in terms of
representation on TV shows
and in films and in news
coverage of the stories
and issues that matter to us,
we still have a ways to go.
And that's a priority
for GLAAD right now.
But media watchdog is just
a small part of what we do.
Other priorities for GLAAD
right now-- workplace
protections for
LGBT people, which
just happens to be in
the news yesterday,
as I'm sure many of you heard.
Just yesterday, our
president, President Obama,
announced he is expected to
sign an executive order that
would ban workplace
discrimination
against LGBT employees
of federal contractors.
It's a huge, huge step.
And we're very grateful
to the president
and his administration
for making that step.
But we're still waiting
for both houses of Congress
to pass the Employee
Non-Discrimination
Act, or ENDA.
Because today, and even
after the president signs
this executive order, if you
are not a federal employee,
it will be legal for you
to be fired in 29 states
if you are gay and 32 states
if you are a transgender
person in this country.
So while we celebrate the
president's announcement,
we know that there's
a lot of work
to be done even afterwards.
And speaking of
transgender people,
transgender rights are
incredibly important to GLAAD.
Because did you know that
41% of transgender people
report attempting suicide
compared with just 1.6
of the general population?
41%.
That doesn't mean that
transgender people are
more likely because of who
they are to attempt suicide.
It means that their lives
are made so difficult because
of the way that our
society is that that
seems like a way to go.
That has to change.
And that's why the stories
of Laverne Cox and people
who come out as transgender
and tell their stories
are so important.
And that's why GLAAD is
so committed to telling
those stories.
There's still so much
misinformation and
misunderstanding
about trans people.
And GLAAD knows
this is a priority.
And it's not just talking
to the greater society
about trans people, but
it's also talking about it
within our own community.
We still within
our own community
have so much to
learn-- hi, water.
There's still even
within our community
so much work to do in the way
that we talk to each other
and understand each
other and our lives.
So we're committed
to doing that work,
not only outside of our
community but within it.
We're also working
to become more
connected with LGBT communities
outside of the United States.
You know how bad things are in
Russia, in Uganda, in Brunei,
in Nigeria, parts of the Middle
East and other countries,
where being gay can and
is a death sentence.
We want to take
what we've learned
from our work on the ground here
at home in the last 30 years
and bring it to other
activists around the world.
It's all part of GLAAD's
new Global Voices
program which we launched
with the Olympics.
And also here at
home, we're continuing
to make it a priority to
connect with that larger
global world with
our Spanish language
and Latino media programs
and people of color.
Especially meaningful to
me because, well, hello.
But seriously, GLAAD is the
only national LGBT organization
with a Spanish-language program.
GLAAD identified early on
that this growing population
would be integral
to our movement.
And the changes we've
seen in the last 10 years
alone are staggering.
You can see the effects
of our work from the way
that our news
stories are covered
on Spanish-language networks
like Univision and Telemundo,
and even in novelas
and television series.
All of this made
possible by the hard work
of our Spanish-language
media department,
which I'd like to tell you
consists of two people.
And they are hard-working,
and they get it done.
Part of their most
recent work is a PSA
that we've put together that
is targeting the World Cup.
And so please keep an eye
out for it because I'm in it.
I mean, who else?
But it's actually a really
exciting time to be at GLAAD.
I've been with the organization
on staff for almost two years
now.
And before that, I used
to be on the board.
And I've hosted the GLAAD
Media Awards a couple of times.
I have a couple of GLAAD
Media Awards myself.
But I'm especially,
especially excited
about being at GLAAD
right now in this moment,
because just this
January, we welcomed
our new president,
Sarah Kate Ellis, who
we welcome from the media world.
And I have such huge
respect for this woman.
She-- get this-- is a lesbian,
married to a rock musician,
yes.
And she and her wife got
pregnant on the very same day.
Bananas.
They have five-year-old
twins, a girl and a boy,
who are not technically twins.
That's their college
essay right there.
Wrap it up.
But under Sarah Kate,
along with much input
from GLAAD's board of
directors and yours truly,
we are taking a three-pronged
approach to the issues
as we move ahead.
GLAAD's goals right now are
three-pronged-- educate,
advocate, and to protect.
We're educating our fellow
Americans on LGBT issues
through TV, film,
and social media.
We're advocating for
LGBT people who are all
too often unprotected
or underserved.
That includes LGBT kids
facing bias in schools,
LGBT couples who
want to get married,
or LGBT employees
facing discrimination
in the workplace.
And with our new
Southern Stories program,
we'll be focusing more and
more on our LGBT brothers
and sisters in the South,
where clearly, we still
have so much work
left to be done.
GLAAD is protecting
the advances,
also, we've made
recently and over
the past three decades
as anti-gay groups
push hard to create new road
blocks to equality so that they
can keep their doors open.
But this is no time to let
our foot up off the gas.
This is the time to push forward
and to realize the dream.
And I try to remind people that
there was a point in 1973 when
Roe versus Wade was decided
on by the Supreme Court.
And we thought the conversation
about abortion was over.
The conversation about
abortion had just started.
And that community who
wanted their right to choose
may have taken their
foot off the gas.
And because of that,
we started to see
a lot of eroding of those
rights as years passed.
And so what we at
GLAAD believe is, now
that we're starting
to see such success,
we're starting to see such
advances in LGBT equality,
part of our job is to make
sure that we keep those rights
and that those laws stay
in place and intact.
And so it really is about
protecting those rights.
And part of that, and
a large part of that,
is continuing to
have conversations
with the American people and
citizens of the world about why
these rights are important.
So you will not see GLAAD
or the LGBT movement
take its foot off of the gas.
We are pushing forward.
And we're going to
realize the dream.
And yes, part of
my work at GLAAD
includes hanging out
with huge celebrities--
it's very difficult-- at
the GLAAD Media Awards.
But it's the hardest
part of my job, chilling
with JLo and Ricky Martin and
Anderson Cooper and Madonna.
But I do what I have to do.
And in fact, this
year GLAAD was very
proud to celebrate 25 years
of the GLAAD Media Awards.
And lest you think it's
all champagne drinking,
the power of the awards reaches
folks all over the world.
They become a platform for
celebrities and notables
to take a stand
for LGBT equality
and come out as allies.
And I brought a
video so that you
can take a look at what it's
been like for the GLAAD Media
Awards in the last 25 years.
Look, I'm doing this.
You should be very impressed.
Ah.
I know.
The most impressive
thing I've done yet.
[INAUDIBLE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[NO AUDIO]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
WILSON CRUZ: No comments
on the hair, OK?
It was 1995.
Thank you.
And yes, the earring
was very in at the time,
so I want to hear nothing
from any of y'all about that.
Do I turn it off?
What do I do?
My hero.
Thank you.
But you can see that
the media awards,
while very glamorous and
glittery and we all get
dressed up and we have a great
time, is really about the fact
that a lot of those moments
that you saw in that video clip
went viral.
They weren't just for
the people in that room.
They were for people who were
allowed to watch those moments
and hear from people that
they recognized and respected
and could relate to.
And those people, by being there
and showing their commitment
to LGBT people, gave
permission to everyone
who saw them do those things
and say those things to also
be allies and also feel
comfortable with who they are.
And that's powerful.
We get accused of
being celebrity-driven.
We're not celebrity-driven.
What we are is people-driven.
And we want people
to know and to feel
that they're supported
by the entire country.
And some of those people
are very famous people
who we respect and we
hold up in our community.
It's very powerful when
we think about what
somebody like
Elizabeth Taylor was
able to do for our movement
and the lives that she saved
and she continues to save, even
today, through her foundation.
So I'm very proud of
the GLAAD Media Awards.
And it's also a time for us to
look at the year in the media
and say, these are the
kinds of representations of
or characters or
news stories that we
want the media to do more of.
It's a way for us to
hold them accountable.
It's a way for us to say thank
you for telling our story
and for driving forward the
conversation for LGBT equality.
So it kills me every time
when I see that video.
Because I think
when you look at it
and you realize
it's been 25 years,
and you think about where
we were 25 years ago,
make no mistake
that so much of that
happened because of the media
awards and because of GLAAD.
And I'm very proud of being
a part of this organization.
But our work today is
also in the boardrooms
and corporate communications
departments in America.
Because let's face
it, corporate America
can shape the narrative
and move mountains,
from Capitol Hill to lunch
rooms and water coolers.
I spoke about the changes
in the sports world.
But corporate America
is also coming out
of the closet for equality
through internal policies,
external actions, and
gatherings like this.
And that's why when
anti-LGBT laws come up
in places like Arizona like
they did earlier this year,
which would have given
businesses the ability
to turn away LGBT people
just because of who they are,
we worked behind the
scenes to advocate
that national corporations
and even sports leagues
spoke out against it.
We also worked
with national media
to make sure that the story
was being told accurately
and to combat some
of the misinformation
that our opponents
were putting out there.
One of the companies that
is a leader and taking
a stand for this community,
for our community,
is Google and has been
Google for a long time.
The tech world is
progressive by nature.
And you understand the
power of communication
and how to create
the platforms we
need in order to reach
people and to reach them
with this message.
I don't think I'm blowing
smoke up your butts
when I say that the
work Google has done
over the past couple
of years has offered
tremendous opportunities
for LGBT equality.
Last year Google
was one of hundreds
of companies to file a brief
with the Supreme Court arguing
that federal same-sex
marriage restrictions hurt
their businesses.
But that was just
one search result
in the dozens of
search results when
you research Google
and LGBT issues.
Some of that we've done
in conjunction with you,
and some you've done
all by yourself.
To name a few, your
Olympic doodles
and Valentine's Day doodles--
including same-sex couples
was right in line with
the majority of Americans
who believe in diversity
and marriage equality.
Second, when you
launched Google+,
users were initially required to
make their gender designations
public.
Some trans and gender
nonconforming users
did not love that.
So Google+ actually became the
first social media platform
to expand their gender field
and tailor privacy settings.
Next, together with GLAAD,
Google coordinated Google+
Hangouts about World AIDS Day,
the amazing documentary "How
to Survive a Plague"--
which, if you haven't seen,
you must see it-- and also to
discuss with interested parties
what might happen for marriage
equality in all states, Utah.
Which still boggles
my mind-- I thought
that was the last one we
were going to get, honestly.
But Google Hangouts have also
been created by your team
and with GLAAD to discuss what's
next for marriage equality
and transgender issues.
Then Google Chrome rolled
out an "It Gets Better"
ad during "Glee," an amazing ad.
It was actually nominated
for a GLAAD Advertising Award
and made history as being
one of the first national TV
commercials about an LGBT issue.
Also, the Google
Zeitgeist "Here's to 2013"
ad was smart enough to include
images of LGBT equality,
including Cassidy Lynn
Campbell, one of our country's
first trans high school
students to be named homecoming
queen; openly gay NBA
athlete Jason Collins;
marriage equality; and champion
of equality Nelson Mandela.
GLAAD was also delighted
to work with Google on last
year's Proud to Love campaign
on Google+ and YouTube.
We were looking for documented
moments of love related
to the LGBT community, whether
it be self-love or family love,
romantic love, community
love, you name it.
Then we took those images
and posted photos on Google+
or uploaded videos to YouTube.
The GLAAD staff-- everyone--
took the challenge.
And I have to say, mine is
particularly cute, so you
should go ahead
and look for that,
because it's worth seeing.
For Pride Month
this year-- shut up,
Lauren-- we've teamed up
again for the follow-up
to that campaign, Proud to Play.
Right now, LGBT athletes like
Jason Collins, Robbie Rogers,
Brittney Griner,
Darren Young, and more
are proud to play a role in
YouTube's newest LGBT pride
campaign.
GLAAD worked with Raymond
Braun of Google and YouTube
to connect with athletes,
LGBT sports groups,
and to promote the campaign.
The campaign honors LGBT
athletes, their supporters,
as well as the YouTube
creators who stand up
for diversity in
sports and elsewhere.
And as part of the
campaign, YouTube's logo,
seen by tens of millions
of people every day,
features a rainbow soccer ball
and leads visitors to the Proud
to Play channel which showcases
videos of LGBT athletes
and allies speaking out
in support of equality
on the field.
Even the Google homepage
paid homage to Proud to Play,
driving googlers from across
the world to the Proud
to Play channel.
So you have a lot to be proud of
as a member of the Google team.
You guys are doing great,
great work in order
to facilitate the conversation.
That's the kind of
impact you're having
on LGBT people and allies
all over the world.
But you're also
making a difference
between these walls,
this workplace
with your LGBT policies.
First of all, you've
got a workplace policy
for LGBT employees, and
you stand behind it.
Google offered increased health
benefits for trans employees
starting in 2011.
And I know you work
hard to bring diversity
to employee ranks and
encourage LGBT hires.
I also hear you've got an
incredible LGBT employee
resource group, the Gayglers.
I know you don't
just celebrate pride
but you inform other employees
about programs and policies
to keep this company
fair and inclusive.
Some Google employees
even went out
to support marriage
equality with a really
incredible and moving
ad called "The Four."
It speaks to both the
pride of the employees
who appeared in
it and the company
that supported you in making it.
So what can you do to make this
spirit of pride and inclusion
going-- to keep it going?
What can you do to
bring in others in?
Well, as we all know,
it's not just policy
but culture at the
company that matters.
So you can be sure to do things
like participate in Spirit Day
this fall on October 16, when
we'll all go purple in a stand
against LGBT bullying in
a national day of support
for LGBT young people.
It's the one day a year that
the whole country comes together
by wearing purple, by
turning their social media
profiles purple in order to
say that LGBT youth should
feel safe wherever they are.
You can wear purple.
You can turn your
online profiles purple.
You can eat eggplant if
that's what you want to do.
But we work with everyone.
We work with the White House,
with Oprah, with the NBA,
with PepsiCo, Times
Square, the "Today" show,
to local schools in Wisconsin
and parishes in the South.
MTV last year changed
its logo to purple,
and so did all of the major
league baseball teams.
We also had every single sports
organization down to NASCAR
turned purple last year.
Lots of organizations will
be doing some incredible LGBT
programming on October
16, Spirit Day.
So to find out more,
you can just google it.
For those of you who
identify as LGBT,
you need to continue
to be out and proud
among your colleagues
and fellow employees.
Talk about your home life.
Put pictures on your desk
of the people you love.
They're called printed photos.
They go in little frames.
They don't have to be
just on your little phone
where nobody sees them.
You can share your
life with people.
It's very 20th century to
have a photo on your desk.
You can continue
to be visible here
at Google and in real life.
Other people will take
your stories and attitudes
with them, take
them home with them.
And who knows what kinds of
minds you will be changing?
Who knows if the mom
in the cube next to you
has a gay child at home and
that is dying to come out
and wants to feel
comfortable doing that?
She can be affected
by the people
that she's met here at work.
Who knows if there's
a co-worker who
wants to respond to some
discriminating or careless
words he heard on
a conference call?
You can help him do that.
You can continue to
represent your company
and personal values of
inclusion, diversity,
and equality.
And you can't go wrong
just by doing that.
And of course, I
encourage everyone
here to get involved with GLAAD.
We have some amazing programs
that you can be a part of.
I've mentioned
some of them today.
But we also have our
San Francisco gala,
which takes place this
year on September 13
at the San Francisco
Hilton in Union Square.
And this year, we're
really changing it up.
It's really about
the people who are
moving our movement forward.
And we're honoring some
incredibly impressive people
who have taken our
movement to the next level.
And a lot of that
is happening here
in the San Francisco Bay Area.
And we want to recognize
this community for the power
that they bring to the movement.
So I encourage you
all to attend it,
to tell your friends
to come to it.
It's a new kind of
event for GLAAD.
And it's really
specific and special
to the San Francisco Bay Area.
And I'm actually really
very excited about it.
So you can also get
on our Twitter feed.
Am I allowed to
say Twitter here?
Is that OK?
AUDIENCE: No.
WILSON CRUZ: No?
OK.
You can go to our
YouTube channel.
How about that?
You can sign up for
our YouTube channel.
You can follow us on Google+.
You can send us your
stories and your feedback.
Because we want to know
how you feel about the work
that we're doing.
And we want your input on
how we can do it better.
You can share your stories,
your personal stories by going
to glaad.org/shareyourstory.
That's what GLAAD stands for
today-- sharing your stories,
shaping the cultural
narrative, and helping you
and your friends
and the people you
love live the life
that they love.
I want to thank you personally
for having me here today.
I'm very proud to celebrate
you, to celebrate Google,
to celebrate the relationship
that Google and GLAAD have
worked so hard to create
in the last few years.
And that relationship is
truly changing the world.
So thank you.
And I'm going to take
some questions now.
So do you need to
move the camera?
God forbid I do
anything off camera.
[APPLAUSE]
Is it on?
No.
And honestly, I am not shy.
I've probably answered
every conceivable question
you can come up with.
So feel free.
We can talk about GLAAD.
We can talk about my career.
We can talk about where
we are in the movement.
We could talk about Google.
Who's going to be first?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILSON CRUZ: Right.
So her question was to go
into a little bit more depth
about how GLAAD is doing
its international work.
Mainly because in so
many of these countries,
if we're talking about
countries like Brunei or Russia
or the Middle East,
more visibility
can actually be very dangerous.
So what we're committed
to doing is actually
working with people
who are already
working as activists in those
countries and reinforcing them
and the work that they're doing.
A lot of these people on
the ground around the world
are creating actions.
And they're doing what
they can how they can.
So we're going in
and giving them
the wealth of our own
experience and knowledge
of how we started
here 30 years ago.
And we're also coming in with
a lot of media experience,
how to engage their local media.
We're not recruiting for them.
What we are doing
is asking them what
it is that they need, what is
that they feel they need help
with on the ground as
far as how do they talk
to their local media, to their
national media, what access
they have to it, how to
start the conversations
with those media outlets.
For instance, when this
whole thing blew up in Russia
with these anti-gay laws
that were passed there,
we actually, along with
other organizations,
brought out a number
of LGBT activists
who had been working
on the ground.
And we brought them here to
the States before the Olympics,
like months before, so that
they could meet people here
who were influencers
and who had experience
early on in the
movement in order
for them to get advice on
how to go about the work
that they were
doing on the ground.
We're also giving them--
we're amplifying their voices
in American media.
Because so much of the
media-- is this thing on?
So much of the media
in their own countries
aren't giving them the space
that they need or deserve.
So what we're doing
is we're getting them
the bullhorn here in the United
States, in American media,
knowing that the media
here in the States
is spread out across the world.
So we're shedding a light
on what's happening there,
knowing that it
will boomerang back,
even if it's just
through the internet.
So it's really about reinforcing
them, giving them the ability
to do their work better,
and training them
on how to use the media locally.
And we're really sticking to
our-- that's our home, right?
How do you amplify your message?
How do you get as many
eyes and ears to the story
that you want told?
And that's the role we
see ourselves playing.
And that's what we've
learned how to do best.
But you're right.
I think you're right in the
sense that it is dangerous.
But we have to remember that
40 years ago, 50 years ago,
it was dangerous here.
And we wouldn't be here
today if there weren't people
who were willing to risk their
lives so that we could get here
today.
And the people we're
meeting in places
like Russia and China
and the Middle East
know that they're putting
themselves in danger.
I think our job as a media
advocacy organization
is to shed a big
spotlight on them.
Just at the media
awards this past year,
we gave out our
very first Advocate
for Change Award, which
is a global award.
And we gave it to
Manny de Guerre,
who is the head of the LGBT
Film Festival in Russia.
And she really is starting
a conversation there.
And we, along with
Dustin Lance Black
and with Bruce Cohen, who went
out there, and Gus Van Sant,
they really put a big
spotlight on those issues
at the time of
their film festival.
And they put
themselves in danger.
There were bomb
threats at the time.
And we celebrated
her hoping that
by people hearing her story
and hearing her struggle,
that there would be more
and more global pressure put
on the government of Russia
to change their laws.
Did that answer your question?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: It seems
lately that there's
been some divisiveness
in the LGBT community.
Particularly, I feel a
lot of trans folk upset
with people like Dan
Savage or with RuPaul.
Is there a role
for GLAAD in trying
to bridge those pieces
of divisiveness?
WILSON CRUZ: Yeah, I think
that's exactly what we
have been doing.
AUDIENCE: Could you
repeat the question?
WILSON CRUZ: Oh, yes, sorry.
So the question was does
GLAAD have a place, a part
to play in helping
bridge a divide that
seems to be being created in
our own community in regards
to language, right?
As far as language in
reference to trans people,
there seems to be two
schools of thought.
And really, there is a
place for GLAAD to play,
and we've been
playing it, which is
how do we manage to have this
conversation without tearing
each other apart.
And it's been very frustrating,
I have to be honest with you,
because I've been working a lot
on this with the communications
team and the programs team.
I can tell you how I
feel about it personally.
And I think I speak
for our staff, as well,
which is I'm not a trans person.
So I have to defer
to trans people
when they tell me how they
want to be referred to.
It is not my place as a gay man
to say that I have the right
to use a particular word in
reference to trans people.
I'd look at it as if I
had a brother or a sister,
and they came to me and
they said, you know,
when you use that
word, it offends me.
As their brother, I
would stop immediately
because I love them, because
they're part of my family.
I don't understand what it is
that people are robbed from.
I don't understand
what people are
robbed when they are asked
to respect people in the way
that they want to
be referred to.
Had I used the word,
the T word, in the past
before I was educated about it?
Absolutely.
I thought it was a funny word.
Now that I know differently,
I do differently.
Maya Angelou died just
a couple of weeks ago.
And that was her
biggest lesson for me--
I am allowed to make mistakes.
But once I am educated enough
to know that I made a mistake,
it's my job to learn that
lesson and change my actions.
I hope that we're starting
to see that there are parts
of our community
who are starting
to learn that lesson as well.
There is a freedom of speech
in this country, obviously.
But your freedom of speech
ends at someone else's nose.
As soon as it hurts
somebody else,
I think you need
to stop, especially
when it's hurting
someone who you
are supposed to consider family.
That's how I see it.
How people refer to
themselves-- that's fine.
If you want to call
yourself something, please,
go right ahead.
How you refer to other
people-- that's another issue.
And I think we've learned
this lesson many times.
We've learned it within our
own community a few times.
We don't use the F word.
We ask people not
to use the F word.
African Americans
have asked not to be
referred to as the N word.
They can call themselves
that all they want.
They do it in rap
music all the time.
If that's what they
want to do, that's fine.
But I don't get that
freedom because I'm not
a part of that community.
So I think there
are lessons to be
learned from those two examples.
But also, I just want us to love
each other a little bit more.
And it's not an attack on
somebody when you tell someone,
that word offends me.
I think people are
feeling attacked.
And it's not an attack.
It's new information
that you get to process
and hopefully do
the right thing.
And I think a lot of this
comes out of the fact
that trans issues are part
of the national zeitgeist
right now.
I think there's so
much education, so much
information about trans people
that we've never had before.
And it's really
coming out of the fact
that the trans
community is empowered
to actually speak up
and say, you know what?
I don't like that.
I didn't like it
then, but now I feel
empowered to say
I don't like it.
And I want you to respect
me enough to treat me
with the respect that I deserve.
So when people say,
oh, well, we used
to be able to use that
word, well, nobody
was feeling empowered enough
to say it was wrong then.
And so we're all
learning something.
It's a big learning curve.
And I hope that the trans
community also allows people
the time and has the patience
to give people the time
to learn the lesson
and come around.
Part of advocacy and activism
is continuing to push.
I get that.
I've been doing
it my whole life.
It's really the
responsibility of the advocate
and the activist to continue
to put the pressure on.
But we always know that it
takes a little bit of time.
People don't just
change automatically.
So there is give and
take on both sides here.
There's the give on the LGB side
to say, OK, I'm getting there.
I understand that
it offends you.
I'm going to get there.
I'm learning.
And then there's the give
on the trans side, which
is I'm going to give you
the time to get there
and continue to ask
you to do better.
But it's a hard one.
And it breaks my
heart to see it.
Bueller?
AUDIENCE: I'm very familiar
with your body of work.
[INAUDIBLE]
WILSON CRUZ: Thank you for that.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It's very impressive.
I feel like I've sort of
grown up with you [INAUDIBLE].
And I think it's really awesome
that your visibility provides
you with this forum [INAUDIBLE].
I think-- were you in Christina
Aguilera's "What a Girl Wants"
video?
WILSON CRUZ: I was
not, but this is not
the first time
somebody has asked me.
And then I watched the video.
And I was like,
oh, OK, I could see
why people would
think that was me.
No, that is not me.
AUDIENCE: Somebody
mentioned that to me.
I was like, oh, I don't know.
WILSON CRUZ: No.
Now I'm here.
No, that was not me.
It's some really great dancer.
I'm a good dancer--
I'm not that good.
But no, that's not me.
I'm not in the Christina
Aguilera video.
That's what he just asked me.
AUDIENCE: Out of all
the things that you've
done throughout the years, what
stands out to you the most?
Or what is your most
memorable project [INAUDIBLE].
WILSON CRUZ: Well, I
would be ridiculous
if I didn't say that Rickie
Vasquez wasn't my favorite.
And mainly because--
thank you-- without him,
there wouldn't have
been anything else.
But also because playing him
was very cathartic for me.
I was 19, 20 when
I was playing him.
And I got to go back in
time a bit to high school
and play my 15, 16-year-old self
and heal a lot of those wounds.
And I left that stuff
sitting on that stage.
I got to play it out and leave
it there and walk away from it.
And so it was a healing
experience for me.
And also, it was the
first time, right?
It was the first time
that we in the States
got to see what
it was like-- what
it is like-- for a
young person questioning
themselves and taking that
journey of self-discovery
and self-acceptance.
And I'm really, really proud
of the way we handled it.
We gave him the time and
the space to love himself.
And I think at the end
of those 19 episodes,
you really did see him embrace
himself and start celebrating
himself as opposed to
being afraid of what
was coming to him.
And I'm really proud of that.
I feel like we empowered
a lot of young people.
And now, when I look back on it,
20 years later-- actually, this
is the 20th anniversary.
August will be the
20th anniversary.
And so I think about all of
the young people who grew up
knowing Rickie
Vasquez, who may not
have known a gay person
at their own high school.
And he could be that
person for them.
And so that when they
were out in the real world
and they met somebody or
somebody came out to them,
they didn't feel that this was
some alien person, that this
was someone that they
understood and could accept.
Do I think that he changed
a whole generation?
No, but I think he helped
educate a whole generation
of young people
and their parents.
So I'm proud of that.
I'm a singer, dancer,
actor at heart.
That's what I was trained to do.
So the fact that I got to
be on Broadway in "Rent"
and do that for a year
and a half-- well,
it was almost two years-- and
play that specific role, that
was a dream come true for me.
I grew up watching Rita
Moreno in "West Side Story."
I would put it on all the time.
And eight shows a week for two
years, I got to be Rita Moreno.
What boy gets to say that?
I'm really proud
of "Noah's Arc."
I think that "Noah's
Arc," while not perfect,
was the first time that we
saw a cast of African American
and Latino gay men who were
well-adjusted and educated
and successful and in love and
looking for love and unafraid.
And I got to play a
doctor who was living
with HIV who was
probably the most
well-adjusted
person in the cast.
And I think that
message is something
that we need to see more of, to
help relieve the stigma of HIV
and AIDS in our community.
So I'm proud of that.
It's like asking me to
choose between my children.
It's very "Sophie's
Choice" to me right now.
But one of the reasons why
I took the job at GLAAD
was so that I only want to
do things that I really love
and that I really
care about and that I
feel like I can
throw myself into.
And working at GLAAD helped
me work directly with studios
and networks to ask for
more of those kinds of roles
and also gave me the
time and the ability
to still pay my bills
and not take roles
that I wasn't in love with.
I'm very lucky in that sense.
And also helped me feel
useful in the world
while I waited for something
great to come along.
And now I get to continue
to work at GLAAD.
And somehow, I'm going to be
doing this series in the fall.
I don't know how
I'm going to do it,
because I'm going to be flying
back and forth between LA
and Atlanta for a lot of it.
But I'm really excited
about "Red Band Society"
and what's about to come.
So I'm a lucky boy.
Or an old man, depending
on how old you are.
AUDIENCE: So when
you were kicked out
of the house at that
stage, what would you
say was your biggest
motivation or role
model, the resource
that kept you going?
WILSON CRUZ: So what kept me
going when I was homeless?
Well, to be fair-- what
most people don't know
is that we made the pilot of
"My So-Called Life" in 1993.
And then we weren't picked up.
The show wasn't picked
up for the fall,
but they held on
to us for a year.
And so they told us in May
that we weren't picked up.
October, they told
us that we were
going to get picked up
for the following year.
So I came out to my
dad after we knew
that we were going
to get picked up.
So I came out to him in
December of that year,
so two months after we got
the pick-up of the series.
We didn't start
filming until April.
So I lived in my car
for like four months.
So what kept me going was
knowing that I had an endpoint.
So as far as LGBT homeless
youth, I was lucky.
Because I knew that
there was a day where
I was going to be
on a TV show, and I
was going to be getting a check.
So all I had to do was
get through four months.
That's not the case for most--
safe to say-- LGBT young people
who are thrown out
of their homes.
It kept me going
to know that I was
going to be able
to tell this story.
Was it difficult?
Absolutely.
And most of that,
let's be honest,
could've been avoided if I
didn't have all this Puerto
Rican pride, ego, that didn't
allow me to ask for help.
I don't recommend it.
I don't think
living in your blue
Chevy Sprint should be
experienced by anybody.
So if there is anybody out
there who's going through that
and is being kicked
out of their house,
there are resources that you can
reach out to, and you should.
I was dumb.
But I also knew that
it was going to end.
I just couldn't bring
myself to ask for help.
That was part of the problem.
Which is why going
through that series
and, like I said earlier,
experiencing a lot of that
and leaving it there helped heal
a lot of my issues around it.
AUDIENCE: You touched
on this a little bit.
But my question is,
what do you feel
like the most controversial
issues in our community are
and the most divisive issues?
I guess it's controversial
to even answer.
WILSON CRUZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILSON CRUZ: The
most controversial
and the most divisive-- [SIGHS]
I mean, it's all
controversial, depending
on where you are in the country.
I think there's a lot of work
to be done in the South, which
is why we're taking on the
South in our Southern Stories
program.
I think there are ways
into the South, though.
There's a lot of work that we
can do through sports programs,
through churches that
are going to allow
us to have these conversations.
Local media is
going to be helpful.
Divisive is really-- the most
divisive issue right now,
I honestly think, is
the one that I was just
talking about earlier.
I think the way we talk to each
other in our own community--
we need to be much more
mindful with each other.
We need to be much more
empathetic with each other.
And it's not just
the trans community.
I also saw something
recently, this conversation
around bisexuality that was
also very troubling to me.
It was a back and forth
about, oh, you're not bi.
You sleep with men,
so you have to be gay.
And the person was like,
well, no, I actually
am attracted to men and women.
And the person said,
well, that doesn't exist.
And that's so disrespectful
and so dismissive.
That may not be your experience.
But that doesn't
mean your experience
is everyone else's experience.
I really want us to be able
to-- there's so much coming
at us from the other side,
from our real opponents,
that I want us to love each
other a little bit more
within our own community.
Because the same people
who hate you for being gay
are the same people who
hate you for being trans.
And we have the same enemies.
And that's why
we're a community.
We're fighting
against the same foe.
And the infighting isn't going
to help us get to our end goal.
And our end goal is the day when
none of that matters anymore.
And you can just live your
life as who you really
are and love the
person that you choose
and be the person that
you choose to wake up as.
That's the end
goal, not I should
be allowed to use this
word because, because.
If you can't give me a
reason why, you should--
that's the thing
that gets me crazy.
Why is that word so
important to you?
Well, because I should
be able to say it.
That's not a reason.
Anyway.
Anybody?
I think we're good.
Thank you so much, honestly,
for having me here.
And thank you for doing this.
And happy Pride.
[APPLAUSE]